impossible de se mettre au vert à
bourbon-lancy à cause de lakovic 19 le
département de saône et loire est
toujours dans le rouge
chez les commerçants on broie du noir la
fermeture de la station thermale pèsent
sur leurs activités
ça représente quand même 40 % de mon
chiffre d'affaires donc l'année dernière
on avait déjà souffert avec donc les 1
100 l'incendié des termes qui avait donc
occasionné une perte de chiffre
d'affaires assez conséquente sur 2019
et là on se retrouve avec cette pandémie
et c'est vrai que c'est compliqué avril
un incendie ravage une bonne partie des
toits des thermes
la réouverture est annoncée en mars 2020
mais le sort s'acharne l'épidémie
mondiale attaque le poumon économique de
bourbon-lancy le tourisme thermal plus
de 350 emplois dépendent directement de
cette activité
c'est 4 millions d'euros par an
d'économies liées au thermalisme
donc c'est important et on a plusieurs
hôtels ans nous avons trois hôtels mais
nous avons beaucoup d'hébergeurs
hébergeurs de curistes qui aussi
attendre l'ouverture de la cure thermale
l'an dernier la communauté de communes
entre arul loiret somme et le
département avait misé sur le tourisme
vert
une solution qui avait sauvé la saison
2010 9 mais qui reste difficile à
renouveler dans le contexte actuel cette
année on aura la problématique des
étrangers puisque apparemment les
frontières ne seront pas ouvertes mais
on peut avoir quand même espérer une
clientèle un peu plus proche une
clientèle qui veut découvrir aussi les
bocages du charolais
s'intéresser un peu plus à se mettre au
vert après cette grande période de
confinement tous espèrent que cette
épidémie arrivera bientôt à son terme
si le département repassant vers la
saison pourrait alors reprendre dès la
mi-juillet